[Music]
morning everyone the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak has arrived in Egypt for the
climate Summit with a pledge to invest
Millions more in clean energy but back
home there's a backdrop of criticism
over the government's reticence over
onshore wind and proposals over drilling
licenses for oil and gas in the North
Sea at least 190 countries will be
represented most of them by their
leaders among them is Rishi sunax and
his headline announcement is more than
65 million pounds for Green Technology
Innovation after leaders arrive and
gather for the so-called family photo
together the real work begins on areas
like mitigation reducing carbon
emissions to limit global warming to one
and a half degrees Celsius
adaptation investment in for example
crops that are more resilient to heat
and also to drought and lost some damage
which is wealthy Nations paying
reparation for their climate impact well
as you saw Hannah Thomas Peter is in
charmel shake and for us and joins us
now hi Hannah very good morning to you
quite a lot for them to get through
yes morning K I mean the backdrop to all
of this couldn't be more urgent
scientists from the World Meteorological
organization warning that the last eight
years are on course to have been the
warmest on record we've seen floods
ravage Pakistan fires and heat waves
across Europe and Beyond really adding
urgency to the meeting here of the cop27
climate Summit and Rishi sunak arriving
having performed that U-turn saying he
wasn't going to come changing his mind
arriving here today going to make some
big announcements we are told trying to
salvage some climate credentials because
there was real dismay and anger that the
UK even considered not turning up here
having been the host of Glasgow cop 26
last year and what about Boris Johnson
former prime minister also here in Egypt
the wild card in all of this is he going
to undermine Rishi sunax position this
is his first trip abroad as prime
minister and there is a lot to keep an
eye on today okay lovely Hannah thanks
so much indeed let's talk about it
should we with the Secretary of State
for business energy and Industrial
strategy that's Grant shops of course
he's joining us from T side this morning
hello to you Mr shapes always a pleasure
um why did rishi's tsuna change his mind
about heading to cop27
well I think uh Rishi sunak's always
been very very keen and has actually
financed a lot of funding in the past uh
on climate change but actually just
coming as prime minister obviously we've
got this huge uh hugely important uh
task of settling the economy the awesome
statement coming up I think he just
wanted to make sure he had that in hand
before jetting off with that I think
having worked on very intensively he's
now gone there and as you say he'll be
making further announcements on climate
later today so there's no more work to
be done now ahead of the 17th of
November on the economy
I think the chancellor still working
very hard on it and I know that I've
been working with with the PM the
chancellor and myself on the the
business the climate the energy aspects
of that but um but I think the you know
the vast uh amount of Works uh been done
and so he felt it was uh you know
appropriate to leave the country but as
ever and I think it's a good thing in a
prime minister his first priority is to
make sure that uh particularly with that
rather choppy period that we've been
through
um that the uh that things are
stabilized here oh you've been working
on it as well the Autumn statement
what's in it
well of course you'll have to wait until
the 17th so not not too long now um
I mean I think as yeah it's a good worth
job okay uh he's gone hasn't he because
Boris Johnson's there that's why the
prime minister's decided to go
well no I don't agree I I look as I said
rishi's actually put a lot of uh funding
into
um climate uh throughout this time as
Chancellor before he became a prime
minister he's out there today uh
announcing uh 65 million pounds for a
green NG uh projects in developing
countries and actually I'm here in in
teesside today
announcing a a very important a lithium
Refinery green lithium Refinery the
first in not just this country but the
first in Europe this is all about being
much more energy uh independent NG's
sovereignty for the UK this will produce
about seven percent of Europe's entire
lithium refined lithium needs in years
to come
need to worry about lithium batteries I
mean they're not particularly stable
batteries are they
um well I mean lithium's involved in all
sorts of batteries from products we use
in homes on mobile phones to Motor Cars
we we drive I've driven an electric car
for the last three or four years seems
perfectly stable to me and actually I've
always thought with
um you know things like electric cars
people think nothing of driving around
with petrol cars with essentially
explosions going on in the engine uh you
know in order to create the create the
uh the the the momentum for the car for
the motor for the engine but you know
that's that with the lecture of vehicles
you certainly have a lot less of of that
going on so okay no I think the safety
record's pretty good
yeah well I think Airlines might
disagree with you many of them do want
to carry them
um that's your physics lesson this
morning kids you can head off to school
now talk to me about fossil uh fuels
though
um profits on fossil fuels should those
um be uh subject to a windfall tax is
that something that perhaps the Prime
Minister should be talking about while
he's over at cup 27.
well I think that might be a clever way
of asking me what's in the awesome
statement again uh but you know we we
will be setting that out and the chance
will be setting that out very shortly I
mean it is the case that because fuel
prices have been so high uh there have
been unexpected uh profits of course but
I think it's important that we do carry
on investing in making sure not on
fossil fuels but on the renewable energy
as well that we've we've got the
capacity we've got the uh the ability to
to get that market moving which is why
the lithium Refinery that I'm talking
about here in the Northeast today is so
important but you will need to wait as I
say till the 17th till the uh to the
awesome statement I think I think you
gave us which measures are in there sure
I think it was a massive hint there so
I'm just going to leave it at that
um but what I do want to ask you about
is international trade I'm looking at
the front page of the times this morning
and basically half of the not
International Trade the International
Development were supporting those that
can't support themselves was point seven
percent of GDP down to point five
percent were told because we got a 4.7
at the moment and according to the front
page of the times this morning half of
that almost half of that is being spent
here in the UK so that's you know that's
just clever accounting isn't it
well I mean they're very strict rules
actually for what uh can qualify uh as
um Aid uh and those those are set down
in a way that that ministers can't just
change uh it's always been the case that
uh people who come to the UK under
certain circumstances Asylum Seekers for
example uh are a part of that
expenditure of course what we've seen is
that large number of people uh traveling
across the English Channel uh with
people traffickers
um and uh and those numbers have been
high and so some of that money is used
in in that way but there's nothing new
that that's always been the case you
were homosexual I think well for five
days
um in total but while you were there you
had a look at the paperwork and you said
got to get some of these Asylum Seekers
out of uh these units were we've seen
what's happened while I've been away and
and the problems that were caused there
why were you so desperate to get them
into hotels
well simply that
um we've got to be careful not to break
the law ourselves by detaining um people
who are able to
be outside of that what is not a
detention center but a processing center
at manston so really just a question of
making sure that we were acting within
the law and and that's something that
the Home Secretary is is continuing to
do now
um so you know I I it really just a
question of making sure that uh we're
first of all trying to do all we can to
prevent people from making that perilous
dangerous Journey being people
trafficked and then secondly making sure
that we keep ourselves within the law uh
not detaining people when in fact they
are able to be moved on rather than kept
in what's just a processing center so we
were breaking the law
well the advice I have was very clear
that we were in danger of doing that if
we weren't acting uh and I did act uh
during six days uh in the job and uh I
noticed that the Home Secretary has
continued to uh act now as well yeah but
the previous Home Secretary that is now
the present Home Secretary I'm sure we
can keep up on that one
um she was breaking the law was she
well I didn't see the advice that she
was um getting what I saw was uh that
the numbers had increased when I got
there uh the advice was very clear
um it was that we needed to do a number
of different things not just actually
moving people out there's a a way of
reconfiguring the processing center in
order to make sure that we were
maintaining uh uh the the kind of
correct legal structure for what is a
processing center not a Detention Center
uh and I took that decision as well and
the Home Secretary has continued on the
same path so I think we're at one about
it because you needed to be done yeah I
didn't see the advice beforehand but I
saw what I was did you ask for it did
you ask to see the previous advice uh
no so I mean normally what happens is
you as as a secretary of state you're
provided with advice and you're invited
to take it into account and make the the
Judgment based of it the advice was very
clear to me I didn't see the advice from
a from prior to me that would be uh
unusual it's not uh information that
came to me
um but I do know that the Home Secretary
has continued along the same path that I
set during that week that I was in the
office uh which was of course before
Rishi sunak became prime minister okay
because as you know the suggestion is
that Zoella bravaman the previous Home
Secretary the president Home Secretary
um ignored legal advice I mean that
would have been wholly inappropriate
wouldn't it if that was the case
half of me I said I didn't see that
advice it's hard for me to comment on um
what I do know is the advice is very
clear to me I acted immediately on that
advice uh it may well be that numbers
have been changing very quickly during
that period with new arrivals and I note
that she has continued along the same
path so as I say I think we're all
moving in the same direction there okay
do you support nurses going on strike
for better pay
well look I think first the first thing
to say is we all remember what an
extraordinary job they were doing my own
dad is I'm sure you will recall because
we spoke at the time was in hospital
through uh covert they were doing a a
great job uh I know that a million NHS
workers got 1 400 pounds rise uh last a
year on top of uh I think a three
percent uh Rise
um I very much hope that the NHS uh
nurses and others can can get this
resolved because uh clearly
um it'd be damaging to everybody if
nurses went on strike we all care about
our NHS we all care about our health
service so so no one would want to see
that happen I think probably including
the nurses so we care about them enough
to give them more money
well there's a there's an independent um
pay body that makes the recommendations
I I believe we accepted it uh last year
um I'm not in a position to sort of
preempt either what they decide or what
the the pay body does but as I say I
know a million workers got 1400 pounds
extra uh last year and you know everyone
it's in all our interests to see the NHS
working we all care passionately about
it we rely on it and uh you know strikes
uh won't help anyone I hope that is
resolved
how do you feel about Gavin Williamson's
messages to the then Chief whip
uh well I don't think there were uh it
was the right thing to do to send
messages like that I I see they must
have been sent in the moment of of uh
frustration
um but you know I think generally it is
the case that it's much better to um you
know write things which you would not uh
live to regret later uh and uh and
especially with with colleagues and
writing things which are uh polites even
if you have a point of view to express I
think is not unreasonable so I I don't
think he was right to send them the
Prime Minister said the the same
um and uh I know that the uh that the
party is going through a process looking
at them at the moment how I mean
how do you feel about working with
somebody who feels it's appropriate to
talk to women like that
well look as I say it's not messages
that I want to to see sense and I would
not send them um they were sent
presumably in a moment of frustration
um and under very different uh
period or atmosphere in Parliament
um and you know it's I always think
never sort of send messages that you're
going to regret in the in the cold light
of day as it were and it was wrong that
he sent them and there is a process now
looking at that
are you going to vote for Matt Hancock
and I'm a celebrity
I'm not no
why not
looking after his constituents um yeah
you know rather than uh in the jungle
somewhere uh so uh no I won't be I won't
be voting for him although I can't
promise I'll be voting for anyone at all
so uh that that might just be a mission
rather than anything else will you be
watching though I mean are you looking
forward to seeing him having to eat
crocodile anus
tempting as that is I I think I'll
probably be focusing on my job as
business secretary uh and uh and I'll be
uh off at uh cop 27 later this week as
well so I fear I might miss him
depending on how long he survives once
again I see what you did
um just a quick thought before I let you
go uh 60 billion pounds in cuts and tax
Rises most of it cuts
well let's wait and see I I say I know
you've definitely your third attempt to
tempt me into commenting on what will be
in the uh awesome statement everyone
knows it's really important that we do
get these books to balance we can't
leave this debt to Future Generations
apart from anything else it's it worries
the financial markets and that has the
tendency to push up uh rates if we're
not careful now uh what Rishi sunak and
the chance of Jeremy Hunt have done is
make sure that uh that that you know the
the concerns of the markets have been
stabilized but what we're we're working
on with this awesome statement is a
package which puts us on a a really good
path to reduce that debt in the medium
term but also support them as vulnerable
people in society so that's what we've
been working on and so you won't have to
wait long to answer all those questions
on the on the 17th of November okay and
it's definitely off worth a pound to see
Matt Hancock and eat witchy grubs
or maybe we'll do that on replay or
something I think
so much indeed for joining us from tea
side this morning thank you
thanks
no several papers are leading with the
climate Summit this morning the
telegraph reports that Britain has
opened the door to paying climate change
reparations to developing nations
as it supports talks on the issue at cop
27 the male leads with Ed miliban's call
for the UK to acknowledge its historical
responsibility and support countries hit
by climate change and the US UK Canada
and Australia have fallen billions of
dollars short on their fair share of
climate funding for developing countries
that's according to the Guardian
newspaper this morning still to come on
the program a year on from Glasgow can
cop27 deliver speaking to Scottish first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon who's among
leaders in charmel Sheikh we'll also
hear from a nurse who's worked on the
wars for 40 years as the NHS faces
unprecedented strike action and not long
after eight o'clock will be joined by
the shadow International Trade secretary
that's Labor's Nick Thomas Simmons
physiotherapists are the latest health
workers planning to vote on whether to
strike over pay it's the first time in
more than a hundred years that the
chartered Society of physiotherapy has
balloted its members they joined nurses
Junior doctors midwives and emergency
call workers all of them could walk out
this winter in what would be the biggest
strike in the history of the NHS Shaman
is Danny by for us at the Department of
Health in central London this morning hi
Sean good morning to you just hearing
there from the minister on duty this
morning basically saying the nurses are
not getting any more I'm guessing the
same for the rest
yes well as you quite rightly point out
physiotherapists are among just the
latest union members are part of the NHS
that are now balloting its members
asking them whether or not they want to
vote in favor of strike action and it is
all overpay and that's because the
chartered Society of physiotherapists
have said um that they actually rejected
sorry a pay award back in September
that's because they said that the offer
was half the rate of inflation and they
believe that the offer in itself was
shocking and insulting and point to the
fact that the people that have remained
in the NHS have faced uh backlogs
massive backlogs and mainly as a result
of the coronavirus pandemic but these
backlogs had already existed before and
now they say that many of the staff in
the NHS are leaving and will continue to
do so unless they are paid what they
believe they be served now
physiotherapists will start voting from
today but other unions have already gone
to the ballot boxes for example the
Royal College of Nursing they balloted
300 000 of its members the results are
meant to be coming back this week but
Union reps there are already pretty
certain that its members will be voting
in favor of strike action they're also
joined by Unison they represent Porters
nurses security guards and so on as well
as the Royal College of midwives and the
British Medical Association as well now
the government have said that they want
um for the unions to carefully consider
the impacts on patients but Union reps
will argue that that's exactly what
they're doing okay Siobhan thank you
very much indeed
in other news the Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski has said his country
is bracing for more Russian attacks on
its power stations over the last month
Russia has focused on striking Ukraine's
energy infrastructure causing power cuts
and rolling outages across the country
the Kiev mer Vitali Klitschko urged
residents to be prepared to leave the
city in a worst case scenario where the
capital loses power and water President
zielinski says millions of people are
without electricity
as of this evening stabilization power
outages continue in Kiev and six regions
more than 4.5 million consumers are
without electricity most of them are now
in Kiev and the Kiev region it's really
difficult
okay
and we'll be speaking to the Ukrainian
ambassador to the UK a little bit later
on in the program meantime some other
headlines for you this hour and England
rugby players are asking for help to
find former bath player Levi Davis who's
been missing for more than a week in
Spain he was last seen at a pub in
Barcelona the 24 year old Winger is also
known for appearances on shows including
celebrity X Factor
the sister of jailed British Egyptian
activist Allah abdul-fatis says he was
stopped drinking water in an escalating
hunger strike coinciding with the start
of the cop 27 Summit abdulfata is
showing a five-year sentence for
spreading false news allegedly many
International observers regard the
charges as politically motivated the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak has promised
to raise the case with Egypt's leaders
19 people have died after a plane
crashed into Lake Victoria while trying
to land at a nearby airport in Tanzania
26 survivors were rescued and taken to a
hospital in the coastal city of Dar es
Salaam
America will vote tomorrow in the
midterm elections Georgia is one of the
key swing States and with an endorsement
from Donald Trump former American
footballer star Herschel Walker is
hoping to win for the Republicans but
his political Journey has been far less
smooth in his career as an athlete
Martha Kellner reports now from Georgia
[Applause]
even in a sea of controversial
candidates Herschel Walker stands out
he's a celebrity a former American
football star endorsed by Donald Trump
and if he wins the senate race in
Georgia it could be decisive in flipping
the balance of power in this country
back towards the Republicans
but Walker is not the candidate they
hoped for
he ran on a message of anti-abortion but
stories from his past have emerged and
been seized upon by his opponent
Marshall Walker paid for an abortion for
his then girlfriend she supported her
claims with a 575 dollar receipt from
the abortion clinic even his own son is
saying Walker is lying Mr Walker your
anti-abortion but two women say that you
paid for their abortions are you a
hypocrite sir how can the voters of
Georgia trust you Walker denies paying
or pressuring women to get an abortion
not that it seems to be affecting him
here
in the shadows of the stadium where his
old team play his supporters are
steadfast do you think that Herschel is
an appropriate candidate for the summer
absolutely what what do you like about
one art vote with Biden one ounce and is
that what you're concerned about most of
all absolutely he's ruined our country
bye you'll vote for Herschel Walker for
the Senate I vote rehearsal just because
he gave us great football I mean yes
absolutely
people here see move to vote by issues
like crying petrol prices and
immigration but blue America is focusing
on abortion rights to pull voters to the
polls
I'm being driven by Nala whose
canvassing potential voters as a younger
woman she had an abortion and wants
others to have the same choice I was not
mentally prepared for that I
um
didn't have the finances for that I
wanted to finish school so yes I made
the decision for myself
that I didn't want to give birth looking
for 19. more than 2.5 million early
votes have already been cast in Georgia
but with hours to go before the polls
open the door knocking continues the
youth vote is really low so we get her
out make a plan for Tuesday okay around
this country Democrats hope their
strategy of focusing on abortion rights
will pay off on Election night Martha
Kellner Sky News Georgia
foreign
Minister Greg Hans traveling to Taiwan
for what will be the first face-to-face
talks since the pandemic our Asia
correspondent Helen Ann Smith is in due
high for us in China now good morning
she looks a bit soggy where you are this
morning tell us more about what's going
on
yeah it is absolutely soggy here I'm in
duhayan southern China at the Chinese
annual air show the timing is really
interesting given the news this morning
that trade Minister Greg Hans is going
to Taiwan that is a very significant
decision he's the first UK minister to
travel to Taiwan since the pandemic and
it won't have gone unnoticed by anyone
not least by China but it comes at a
time of real heightening tensions
between China and Taiwan a time where a
number of Western governments have
chosen to send representatives there and
while that may send its message China is
sending its own message today a show of
real military strength I just want to
show you around pic okay it is raining
very very heavily but what we're at the
uh the Chinese air show it happens
annually and it is a celebration of all
things Aviation here in China there's
incredible varieties of things here
there's aerobatic demonstrations from
the Chinese equivalent of the Red Arrows
there are helicopters here there are
drones there are all sorts but what it
is also is a chance for China to show
off the latest in its cut Edge military
technology a chance for it to show just
how strong just how developed its
military is and I just want to point
your attention to this lineup of jets
here because these are the very family
of jets that on a daily basis now are
being sent to fly in Taiwanese airspace
and there was a time where that would
have been considered an unusual and
provocative activity not now and these
these days we're seeing multiple Jets a
day pass over What's called the median
line the sort of a de facto Maritime
border between Taiwan and China just
yesterday 21 such Jets just like these
ones made that journey and it's just
worth stressing just how unusual it is
to be allowed so close up to Chinese
military equipment and that in itself is
a real demonstration of strength so
China sending its own message today a
message that its military is developed
it is modernized it is transformed from
what it was five or so years ago and it
is a military they say that would be
ready to fight an international War if
it whatsoever come to that of course the
world worries very much about China ever
moving to invade uh Taiwan but a real
escalation of tensions uh on both sides
okay for now Helen I'm thank you well if
you scan the QR code here we go on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest edition of The Sky News Daily
podcast today Sally Lockwood is looking
at why China is still chasing a strict
zero covered policy with its people
facing regular lockdowns and
restrictions you can subscribe to the
Daily for free wherever you get your
podcast
I love this story The Comedian Peter K
has announced a return to stand up with
his first live tour in 12 years
hey garlic bread hey it's the future
hey when you're back on tour
next month
it is the future uh 49 year old who's
been largely absent from the public eye
announced the new tour with a Twitter
video uh Peter Kay says tickets will
start at 35 pounds the same as his last
tour in 2010 which is the cost of living
crisis
Toronto Saturday a Shetland pony called
poverkill is being entered into the
Guinness book of records as the world's
smallest ever horse at three years old
he stands just 50 centimeters tall
perhaps the perfect size for his work as
a therapy for children and also for the
elderly his instructor hopes the
official world's smallest horse
designation will be announced soon it's
even got a little ramp look at that
still to come on the program for you at
Nicholas sturgeon she where is she stay
tuned find out here on Sky News very
welcome to join us this Monday morning
you've missed the business secretary if
you've only just tuned in he's been
talking about his time as Home Secretary
what advice he was given so as not to
break the law when it came to migrants
and being kept in detention centers and
this is what he said about the former
now present Home Secretary
the advice I have was very clear that we
were in danger of doing that if we
weren't acting uh and I did act uh
during six days uh in the job and I
noticed that the Home Secretary has
continued to act now as well yeah but
the previous Home Secretary that is now
the present Home Secretary I'm sure we
can keep up on that one
um she was breaking the law was she
well I didn't see the advice that she
was um getting what I saw was that the
numbers had increased when I got there
uh the advice was very clear
um it was that we needed to do a number
of different things not just actually
moving people out there's a a way of
reconfiguring the processing center in
order to make sure that we were
maintaining uh uh the the kind of
correct legal structure for what is as I
say a processing center not a Detention
Center
now let's unpack that should we tomorrow
is standing by for us I know that you
were listening to that interview good
morning uh tomorrow what was he saying
well this is very interesting as manston
and the whole issue of what the
government does um when migrants have
been processed here continues to be in
the news Grant shouts remember three
weeks ago Sue Ella Bradman resigned as
Home Secretary he became Home Secretary
and was there for just six days before
the government collapsed where she seen
that came in and moved him now during
that period he says he came in was given
clear advice that the home office was in
danger of breaking the law which could
invite some very expensive legal action
against the government because the
conditions there were overcrowded he
says I acted during those six days as
Home Secretary and I understand he
immediately started commissioning hotels
and trying to get accommodation ready
through the agencies the government uses
for that to get people out of there the
question is of course what was happening
the previous day when Sue Ella Braven
was there did she ignore a officials
advice to move people out of there he
says he hasn't seen what she was shown
but can it have been that different from
one day to the next and also that the
numbers were moving very very quickly
but I think this will reignite questions
about whether she was told to do that
and didn't do so also thought on Gavin
Williamson and his petulant messages to
the former Chief whip as Richie Cena
came in promising professional
government full of integrity and
accountability and of course a second
crisis to hit him after the Sue Ella
bravman issue is why Gavin Williamson is
now back in cabinet minister without
portfolio and his have been we now know
sending these aggressive looking
messages to the former Chief whip Wendy
Morton and his colleague say it's like
unacceptable Rishi sunak speaking to
reporters overnight on his trip to cop27
says it's unacceptable but why has there
have there been no consequences
especially since it emerged that the
prime Minister was warned there was a
complaint pending against Gavin
Williamson who of course has been sacked
by two former Prime Ministers by Theresa
May and Boris Johnson in the past if
that complaint was pending why did he
appoint him to the role and I think
there'd be more questions about Rishi
cnx judgment with yet more bad headlines
involving Gavin Williams I think you're
absolutely right and I also think that
we've got tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock we can talk more about that
thanks so much indeed thank you well as
the days get uh shorter darker and
colder you might be dreaming of escaping
overseas for a few days we're going to
be talking about that in just a moment
or two before that though I also want to
tell you about what's happening in charm
El Sheikh and we know that Rishi sunak
has arrived there overnight we've got
some pictures of him there I think he's
going to be taking part in the um family
photo as it's called very shortly indeed
um
also there also taking part I'm sure
will be at Nicholas sturgeon she is the
SNP leader and the first minister of
Scotland and she is joining us now
hello Mr Jones good to see you as always
thank you very much indeed for joining
us on the program tell us why you've
decided to go hi
it's really important that governments
at all levels contribute to these
discussions and clear our part in
meeting our own obligations domestically
but encouraging greater progress
globally Scotland is the European
co-chair of an organization called the
under two Coalition which brings
together devolved governments like mine
with States regions across the world
together we represent something like 50
of the global GDP and many of the levers
for tackling climate change lie in our
hands so it's really important that
everybody with a part to play does that
to the full Scotland was also the host
of Corp 26 last year in Glasgow and the
Scottish government played a part in
putting some key issues at this Corp on
the agenda loss in damage for example so
again important to be here to be
encouraging collaboration and playing
our part in hopefully a good outcome
from this Corp is we can continue to
address the accelerating emergency of
climate change
but isn't that what Rishi sunak is doing
already I mean could you not have done
what you needed to do remotely
no I think having I think this is the
fifth Corp that I have participated in
and it's really important to be here to
be having the discussions to be playing
our part in finding the solutions now
Rishi sunak is here I welcome that I
think it is right that he is here but if
we look in a UK context at many of the
the decisions that will determine
whether or not the UK as a whole meets
its own climate obligations many of them
for Scotland are responsibilities of the
Scottish government renewable energy for
example Energy Efficiency changing how
we we travel so it's really important
that everybody was a part to play does
that to the full and I think it is vital
that the connections that are made here
are are made and that we all do that
work and if you speak to many
campaigners many governments
particularly from the global South they
warmly welcome Scotland's contribution
here generally on this issue but
particularly on the issue of loss and
damage without the intervention last
year of the Scottish government and this
is not just my view you'll hear this
from campaigners here it is unlikely
that we would be now seeing that issue
with the prominence that has in Egypt I
think we've all got a part to play here
climate change affects all the visit
affects some more than others but every
single one of us has an obligation to
play our part in tackling it
including the leader of Glasgow city
council Susan Aiken who's also gone even
though she's just announced um 120
million pound black hole in the city's
budget
yes Glasgow was the host of cop last
year Susan is here to hand on at the the
court responsibility to Egypt to Shamel
Sheikh this year Glasgow Scotland's
biggest city Scotland will meet its
climate change targets if the city of
Glasgow doesn't do that you know I mean
I I'm not arguing with your line of
questioning here but why we're here but
actually what matters is what's been
discussed here what the focus is on
implementing the progress made at
Glasgow what the commitments will be
coming out of this cup climate change
you know even given the turbulence of
the year we've just lived through
climate change is the biggest obligation
the biggest challenge the world faces
right now if we don't all of us leaders
at all levels of government if we don't
take this seriously increasingly
seriously if we don't make the right
commitments Implement those commitments
then we're not going to have a planet
worth handing on to Generations to come
there are fewer more important things
than climate change but in the here and
now it's also important to improving the
security of an energy supply of making
energy more affordable that is actually
how we save the planet as well so I I
think there would be more uh pertinent
questions I think to ask for people like
me and Susan Aitkin if we weren't
playing our film part in discussions
like this and not just playing our part
in discussions but actually showing the
leadership that we need to see if the
world is going to properly address this
challenge I suppose
um my viewers and your constituents
might say what is important is the cost
of living crisis and it's costing money
to send you and others the Glasgow city
council Etc and also the carbon
footprint
look you will find here I'm here in the
the main Pavilion of cop27 and there are
Representatives around me of devolved
governments of uh States and other
countries of German lender that there
will be governments at all levels
represented here we would be abdicating
our responsibility if we weren't in here
playing our part in meeting these
challenges there is of course a cost in
all sorts of ways to tackling climate
change but there is a much much bigger
cost associated with not tackling
climate change and that's how we've got
to see that the cost of living certainly
occupies my government day in and day
out right now but dealing with the cost
of living also at Necessities dealing
with the issues around climate change
the route to more secure energy to
cheaper energy is a transition away from
fossil fuels to renewable energy and
that is Central to the whole climate
change agenda again you know why is a
country like Scotland here Scotland is
an oil and gas producing country we've
got an obligation to show leaders ship
in that transition away from fossil
fuels notwithstanding the challenges and
the difficulties that present to us so I
think if we went and did a stop I
remember speaking to you on the ground
in Glasgow last year if you did a straw
poll around people represented here and
asked them whether they thought it was
important for Scotland to be represented
you'd get an overwhelming vote in favor
of that because there's a recognition of
the role we've got to play but also the
leadership that Scotland has shown
okay um I thought while I've got you on
Matt Hancock going into the jungle
I I think it's disgraceful actually I
I'm not particularly interested in how
he gets on in the jungle but you know
most of my interactions with Matt
Hancock over the past few years when he
was so uh UK Health secretary were over
covered and you know we're not yet
properly out of covert we certainly
haven't had uh the full public inquires
that we need to have and to see him I
think demeaning the office that he used
to hold and uh also I think doing a real
disservice to those whose wives have
been impacted by covert I think it's the
wrong decision but there are many many
more important things for all of us to
be focusing on right now than whatever
Matt Hancock chooses to get up to okay
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much for taking the time always
appreciated
and to you thank you let's bring in the
Greek minister of Tourism should we
evangelize hello to you good to see you
thank you for joining us on the program
we could just start with cop27 there and
then and widen the debate after that how
worried are you about climate change at
global warming and its impact on on
tourism and Greece well first of all
it's an honor of the beans can use thank
you very much thank you for coming
secondly yes of course we're worried and
of course
we're campaigning on that 2023
sustainable touristic model low carb
emission friend of the environment
eco-friendly Echo islands in Greece
which means islands with renewable
energy we started last year with Simi
and halki hulky and
and we're looking into bringing that
into hotels Resorts clean beaches Clean
Cities uh
uh it's not going to be easy of course
it costs in the middle of a war in the
heart of Europe after 80 years
incredible inflation energy crisis the
prices are going up but we've got to
keep on pushing forward because we owe
to the Next Generation what can British
jurists do to try to help you in this
well first of all three million Brits
this year in Greece amazing thank you
very very much for that in branded
destinations and alternative
destinations we love the bridge for that
I think it was number one destination
for for for Great Britain this year and
uh why do you think they have a culture
what is it what is it that appeals to
the Brits so much about Greece do you
think
well you see them out of the box when
there's 13 or 14 or 15 degrees here
during the during the summer so you can
imagine with the weather in Greece how
how nice it is and cause it is I think
they blend in the Greeks love them they
enjoy themselves in the islands in the
mainland they have the Exquisite Greek
food they they dance with the music they
eat the sweets they
buy the beach up on the mountains during
the summer time but off season also they
started coming earlier now J2 is a jet
we're going to keep on flying for
November and then March and April so a
Greek weekend oh good I like that let's
see what you did there yes not just our
students here and how we love Christmas
in London and how we keep on coming back
but the bridge I think have decided they
want to talk about vacations they talk
about Greece yeah which is your
particular favorite part of Grace mine
yes and the minister of Tourism imagine
if I chose
128 inhabited islands and the mainland
also I think that people travel as
tourists and of course
you keep on
adventuring in in Greece and keep on
finding out new destinations that's the
magic of it it doesn't stop it's a
unique experience it's a state of mind
because since the ancient days until
today
we love to host people strangers
foreigners feed them give them time to
drink give them a bed to sleep and then
off they go it's it's a part of our
culture and of our DNA but it is
becoming more and more difficult to have
sustainable tourism or not how do you
turn that corner how do you make
sustainable tourism the first thought
when when tourists get on a plane well
first of all I think one of two
Travelers from now on we'll travel
in accordance with that our airline
companies and carriers thinking about
low carbon emission yes we go on that
plane do results and and hotels take
care of the environment and recycle the
the garbage for example yes we got the
resort our cities and beaches clean yes
we expect that country or city and we
visit there so our program is a program
of infrastructures public
infrastructures which we will spend
money on to be able to upgrade them in
that extent so how we deal with our
waste how we deal with the water how we
deal with a better location for the
cruising industry in our Islands how we
deal with private Investments as I said
you know to be able to sustain uh and
it's not it's not going to be easy it's
a transition that you need to push
forward and it's one step at a time but
that's our goal in terms of
communication but in terms of
infrastructures also and I think that we
will be a Pioneers since we are one of
the top touristic branches in the in the
world we're seeking to show the way to
everybody else it's not easy to
transform an island into a sustainable
destination but we did it yesterday is a
small island is a small island but it's
already there so we've proven to the
world that's doable of course there are
issues to be taken into account since
the costs of energy are huge nowadays
but this is something that happens now
we're going to deal with it now but also
have a ride into the future okay it's
good to see you Minister thank you for
taking the time thank you for coming
this morning we really do appreciate it
thanks waiting for you next year
I can't decide where'd you go you
couldn't Chase Ron for me it's good to
see you thank you thanks a lot let's
have a look at our climate change data
should we the right of the screen shows
how the UK's power is currently being
produced on the top left you can see how
much warmer the Earth is now than in
1880 that's when modern record keeping
began and finally the bottom left the
total amount of CO2 emissions in
millions of tons in real time
if you're with us earlier you'll know
that we were chatting to the business
secretary about what's happening with
the NHS facing the biggest strike in its
history with physiotherapists joining
doctors nurses paramedics and other
health care workers voting on whether to
strike over pay with me now is uh Dave
Carr who was an NHS nurse for 40 years
High hi there it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning did you vote to strike I
will be voting to strike yeah yeah why
um I think that we have to see what's
happening in the NHS at the round about
why nursing and other health workers are
in for strike action and I think that
the first thing that we need to get
across is not just about money in our
pockets it's about the sustainability of
the NHS in nursing we're currently
working in England alone with 47
000 vacancies there are critical
incidents declared every day where
operations are canceled and therapies
are delayed
um we have
um
situations where we cannot discharge
patients back into the community because
of the social care crisis and we know
that that's because of Staff as well
um we are constantly facing pressures of
short staffing on our walls in our
critical areas in our a e departments
and it's compromising patient care so
for a lot of nursing staff it isn't just
about money it is about being able to
deliver safe patient care
yeah you talk about operations having to
be canceled but of course more will have
to be canceled hypnosis go on strike
well I think that there's there's the
Crux of the matter really we are unable
to recover from the covid pandemic
without a Workforce plan we are losing
more nurses just than we're recruiting
at the moment and we are never going to
get on top of that you're looking at a
couple of years for non-urgent
operations now and even urgent
operations we haven't necessarily always
got the staff to match those and I think
that what we're saying what we pleading
with the with the government is if you
and the country if you want an NHS
that's fit for purpose and can care for
your families and your loved ones safely
you have to pay staff to work in those
environments I could go to the United
States and earn three times what I'm
earning now I could go to Canada
um or an Australia and New Zealand and
earn double what I'm doing and a lot of
our staff are doing that now and our
student nurses when they qualify in the
UK are saddled with huge tuition feed
debt as well it's an unsustainable model
at the moment it's not working it is
broken and we are seeking to take strike
action to to not just to to deal with
the massive loss of earnings I've lost
about
um 15 of my earnings over the last 10
years but it is so that we can recruit
and retain people inside the NHS and do
you from what you're saying we need to
change the way that the NHS operates
it's not just about paying medical
professionals more it's about changing
the way the NHS operates in in totality
well I mean I think we need a proper
plan about where the NH is I mean that's
a big argument about um how how do we
deliver Public Health I mean we've just
gone through a massive pandemic crisis I
mean I work both waves in a critical
care unit across the roads and Thomas's
during that pandemic and we've not
recovered from that in terms of the the
damage it's done to the staff
um and but we need to look at what our
populations Health needs are and how we
deliver that but if you look at other
areas in the Health Service like GP
Services now they're collapse in our
health service is not about to be broken
it is broken it is not working at all
how do we fix it well I think the first
thing we need to do is recognize that if
you want a Health Service that works and
not a two-tier system where people have
to go to the private sector to get their
operations you have to pay the staff and
you have to attract staff and you have
to keep staff in inside those areas we
don't want to go on strike no nursing
staff wants to go on strike I spent two
years you know along with my colleagues
risking Our Lives to keep people alive
this is not an option that's taken
lightly
um but we think that this is the only
option we've got now because we've got a
government that's not listening
and if they don't pay more
if they don't pay more then there will
be strike action um we were speaking to
the business secretary earlier and he
was saying they're not going to pay you
any more money well
that's interesting
um we've seen the government make
u-turns on lots of things I mean
obviously we watch Liz trust crash the
economy recently and we did that with
with dropped Jaws especially off the way
the pandemic was handled and the late
lockdowns that gave us a huge amount of
extra work inside the NHS I don't think
the government's fit to to look after
the economy let alone the NHS I mean
maybe it's time for a general election
and get uh you know a a leadership in
that is prepared to recognize how
important the NHS is to this country so
they were out of time it's great to talk
to you do keep in touch thanks very much
thank you very much a lot still to come
in the next hour here on the program
we're going to be hearing more about
what the business secretary had to say
to us today not least about nurses but
also about one of his colleagues who
sent a very fruity and unnecessary some
might say text messages to a colleague
being very disparaging about her uh what
do you think about that station